all right what's up people we are barely
24 hours out of the election people are
going bananas they're going bonkers
they're going crazy in the streets well
we now have president elect Trump
president elect Donald Trump try to
think back to two years ago five years
ago ten years ago 20 years ago for those
little older Donald Trump is gonna be
the president the United States that is
the situation that we're in at the
moment oh my god all right so there's
there's so much to talk about here
people really are going completely crazy
I actually think that there's a lot of
good that can come out of this there's
going to be a huge freakin mess for a
while there's a strange feeling in the
country right now which we knew was
coming whether Clinton won or Trump won
you know as I said yesterday it was sort
of like we've all just been like [ __ ]
basically for a year and then we had the
climax was yesterday and now it's we're
all just like it's after and we're
looking at each other like oh [ __ ] now
what all right so here's what we're
gonna do
I've got a mirror monitoring the
comments here on YouTube as always if
you are a patron member and you comment
in patreon you will get preferential
treatment but I'll do a little Q&A I'll
share my thoughts look my overriding
thought and I said this to everyone that
would listen to me in LA privately when
I was at parties here and talking to
friends and family over the last couple
weeks I was saying and I said it I think
I said it on rogue in the day before the
election and I certainly said it in some
of these live streams I really thought
this thing was 5050 the entire time
especially in these last couple weeks
that ultimately what it was simply gonna
come down to was turnout and that
clearly clearly the Trump people were
enthused and the Clinton people were
begrudging ly supporting her not
everybody of course there were some
people that were totally on with her but
there was a lot of begrudging all the
Bernie people I'd have stayed home or
begrudgingly voted or some of them
didn't vote some did vote etc etc so
there was just so really you knew it was
gonna come down to turnout and you know
for me
because I'm I do this show and I'm
online and I'm on Twitter and Facebook
and all that and I see the types of
interactions out there I saw a
tremendous amount of enthusiasm for
Trump and plenty of people when I would
call Trump out and stuff would give me
[ __ ] for things but I saw a lot of
enthusiasm there and very little for
Clinton now the X Factor is that it's a
it's hard to actually figure out what
does online traction mean what does
sending a thousand peppe's and her on
base
does that actually mean you're going to
vote well I guess the answer that we
found out is that there is some value
there that when Trump was drawing these
massive massive crowds even if the polls
showed he were down he was down by a
little bit there was some value to those
massive crowds so the polling it seems
like the pollsters are out of business
I've been saying for months these polls
were meaningless because Trump was
bringing in a whole group of new people
I don't have a landline I haven't had a
landline in 20 years probably at least
15 years and they pull people on
landlines and it just the whole system
seems antiquated so first of all I want
to start with just the absolute positive
that I think whether you're a trump
supporter watching this or you're a
Hillary supporter or Gary Johnson
supporter you're an anarchist or you're
waiting for the zombie invasion I think
you can we're all going to agree on this
part which is regardless of what you
think about Trump the big wind in
America yesterday was that the
mainstream media is tumbling fast and
the ugly alternate voices and I like to
believe that I'm one of them but some of
these voices that are cracking through
the [ __ ] is prepackaged nonsense
where you watch super-delegates like
Donna Brazile pretend they're analysts
and people like Alma gala who is a
consultant for a Hillary super PAC
pretending they're analysts and plenty
of Trump people doing it too and it's
all on both sides of former george w
bush you know officials that are on CNN
all that bull [ __ ] and we've all become
so aware of that cracked last night and
look the mainstream media has been
crumbling for a while and online media
has been rising I think this election
got its complete parity and I think
starting today I think we're actually
now taking the lead now they're going to
hit back hard
there's no doubt about it they're not
gonna give up easily they still have you
know huge amount of the money of
resources we're a little independent
show here that's basically funded by the
3,000 youth that join us on patreon
every month but we're growing fast and
that's awesome but there are other
people like us that are doing cool stuff
in the online space again people whether
I disagree with them or agree with them
or not it's irrelevant you know Shapiro
and Crowder and a whole bunch of other
people so so that to me is the main
takeaway for getting the politics for a
second the media thing it has been
rattled now by the way I like to quote
Ben Parker Peter Parker's uncle with
great power comes great responsibility
and the media the mainstream media has
had great power for a long time and they
forgot the responsibility part they
forgot that they were supposed to be
guarding the Republic that they were
supposed to be the Fourth Estate
watching the people in power the
politicians and making sure that they
weren't doing shady [ __ ] instead the
media started aiding and abetting them
now look I'm just one guy I tell you
guys what I think I do the best I can
and I try to have some standard of
integrity when I'm doing it but the risk
of course with now fully trusting online
media is you I don't have to say who but
there's a plenty of shitty online media
too so now we've got a whole new set of
noise and people and you got to decipher
some truth in that so I think
deciphering truth through the noise is
going to be one of the real challenges
for all of us moving ahead and I fully
include myself in that because I have to
figure out what I believe too I have to
figure out what a reputable sources and
things like that by the way you didn't
see my interview with David Sirota who I
think is just fantastic who this entire
election was calling out all the
[ __ ] and got a ton of [ __ ] for how
they recommend you did I think you
posted that last Monday so okay so Amir
is here she's monitoring the comments so
she's going to give me some comments
preferential treatment to anyone on
patreon first so yeah my main takeaway
is that mainstream media was crushed and
that's really good and then the other
takeaway and I think it's just it's a
it's a half a step below the mainstream
media being crushed is that not only was
mainstream media crushed but the social
justice warriors this is this incessant
need and desire to call everyone a
bigoted homophobic racist and an
islamaphobe and a sexist and a ablest
and all this epic [ __ ] just
blanketly blaming cisgender white males
for everything it's just dribble and
nonsense and there was a huge
repudiation about last night enough of
this garbage judging people as
individuals not as the collective and I
think that for the people that voted now
by the way 46 percent of America didn't
vote and about half the vote went to
Hillary and half like the Trump's that
means only about 25% of the country
voted for Trump which is kind of
depressing but that's a different topic
altogether that all said the people
voted against this [ __ ] he's cruddy
state cries screaming on stuff and again
that doesn't mean real racism doesn't
exist it doesn't mean real bigotry and
xenophobia doesn't exist
but we have to address that as such and
not by blanketly calling everyone we
disagree with one of those nonsensical
Butler buzz words that crush
conversation sorry so I'm gonna go to
Mira and some questions I cannot you
know I'm happy to talk about anything as
always and all right here we go and by
the way guys we still know YouTube has
confirmed there is a some sort of bug on
our channel that's what they're telling
us so into our videos are not going out
to our entire feed so if you can share
this if you can like it get it on your
YouTube feed or tweet it or whatever
else you'll help us overcome the magical
bug that by the way is hitting some
other free-speech channels like Prager
University like a shot a video for and
God said okay somebody that's about the
third party blaming I haven't heard too
much third party blaming actually today
but there is some look Gary Johnson I
think got only one point seven percent
someone can correct me on that wrong I
think one point seven percent and Jill
Stein didn't even get that much so it
didn't have much of a dent now the
election was pretty close in terms of
numbers cuz Hillary actually got more
popular vote than Trump did so he got 3%
okay so then still what's that and Jill
Stein got one okay so Gary Johnson got
three Jill Stein got one so they didn't
make a huge dent that sort of standard
third party dent you know you guys at
this point I'm pretty sure you guys all
know my feelings about Gary Johnson I
wanted a libertarian to be in this
to make the case for libertarianism make
the case for limited government for low
taxes for strong defense so you don't
have to use it for the role of
government to actually be discussed he
unfortunately just wasn't a great
standard bearer for that cause and I
think actually did damage to the
libertarian cause by by not being good
but I hope they'll be able to regroup
and get some libertarian and classical
liberal ideas focused on the individual
and the economy I hope that they'll be
able to regroup by 2020 I don't suspect
that they will because they never seem
to learn from their lessons maybe that
has something to do with the psyche of a
libertarian I don't know
Joe Sun I don't think she really
affected it in any way
there as I said the real thing that
happened here is that the Trump people
came out passionately maybe maybe his
strategy you know I would recommend you
know Scott Adams who was on my show the
creator of Dilbert really understood I
think the way Trump did this the way he
used tactics to win I think that there's
a real explanation of how Trump pulled
this off he'd to find all of this stuff
crumbling with WikiLeaks and all this
stuff and Trump and Trump just
constantly attacking and Hillary
attacking - he was just the better the
better attacker and the stuff on her was
really damaging and I think people that
were on the fence or the average Bernie
voter right that really didn't like her
but was purging Lee going to do it by
the time Election Day rolled around they
heard enough about WikiLeaks enough
about the corruption and the DNC stuff
and all that but they were probably just
like you know what I'm not even gonna
vote and and then yeah yeah Hillary won
the popular vote she lost the electoral
college this is exactly what happened to
Al Gore back in 2000 our system needs
some change I mean what is the reason
really at 2016 that if you win the
popular vote you don't win the electoral
college college back in the day it made
some sense relative to be at small
states and because information traveled
very slowly we wanted to guarantee this
is one of several reasons why we had it
but they wanted to guarantee that the
candidates would actually go to all the
states because otherwise why would you
ever go to Montana where very virtually
no one lives so there was reasons for e
now it seems like it's more
just the two-party monolith that
actually is crumbling but there's so
many interesting storylines here I mean
the fact that Paul Ryan this morning
looked elated he has looked so defeated
the last couple weeks but grudgingly
sword a kinda supporting Trump as Trump
was constantly mocking him and making
fun of him and you know Trump who is
attacking rinse Priebus the head of the
RNC this whole time he brings him up on
stage last night like there is gonna be
a new realignment but mark my words what
I've been saying for at least a year and
I don't know anyone else that's been
saying the split that you see on the
left on the right that everybody was so
happy to talk about which now actually
seems to be coalescing it seems to be
coming together and healing it's coming
to the left because the Bernie people
have almost nothing to do with the
Hillary people at this point and there's
gonna be a new group of people - that
are sick of both of them and you know
the people that aren't into the
socialism stuff as much as Bernie but
are also sick of the Hillary corruption
that's a that might be the classical
liberal part if you want to get some
people like me back into it being
interested in the Democratic Party as
opposed to now where I feel like I have
no party
so it's coming to the left - but what a
what a what a crazy night inform guesses
on who again cabinet positions well if
we know if Trump is into one thing it's
loyalty right he loves loyalty so who's
he gonna be loyal to I would guess that
Rudy Giuliani is probably gonna be
Attorney General I know that sounds
scary to some people and you know over
the last year and especially his speech
of the RNC was so over-the-top
ridiculous I do remember my my great
grandparents and my and my grandma lived
in New York City for virtually their
whole lives and when I was a kid we used
to go into New York City before pre
Julie I when Dinkins was the mayor and
towards the end of Koch so I'm talking
like mid eighties early 90s and I
remember how dirty and disgusting the
city was in Times Square was gross and
there were drugs everywhere and all that
stuff and I remember thinking as a kid I
would never want to live in here it
seems gross Giuliani came in and cleaned
up that city you may not like him for
this that or the other thing but he did
clean up the city so I and he did it he
obviously did a good job there 11
let's put aside some of the rhetoric
since then you know he also really did a
lot to defeat organized crime in New
York so he could be an interesting
Attorney General I think um I think that
Secretary of State could maybe maybe go
to a guy like John Bolton who I think is
a pretty decent guy and again when I'm
talking about these people just to be
clear I don't agree thing about all of
them John Bolton if you can't picture it
looks a little bit like a walrus that's
very bushy mustache he was the United
States representative to the UN under
george w bush strikes me as a pretty
decent principled guy he was gonna run
for president this time around but
decided not to i think chris christie
will get something maybe chris Christie
could be as her attorney general instead
of Giuliani because he was a former
prosecutor
um who else yeah I mean you know who you
know that maybe the guy like Ben Carson
is gonna get something and maybe a
Fiorina maybe even uses Ted Cruz in a
way maybe for Supreme Court I mean which
I would not be happy with but anyway I
think you know that he's loyal and he's
gonna pick his own people hopefully it
doesn't pick Trump family members for
everything people yeah so the crux of it
was that some of you guys are seeing
some rioting and fighting and somebody
mentioned that there in the Empire State
Building right now there's there's riots
was that oh they are they can hear you
okay I just like paraphrase you know so
what can you do about and then you know
all the people that are defending Trump
people on Facebook and all this stuff
this is the worst thing you can possibly
do it is so important to hear from
people that think different things than
you follow people on Twitter that you
agree with them that you disagree with
if you lose a friend because of politics
you know I mentioned this a couple weeks
ago but for this election my basically
my like four of my goo
old I'm one of the force of three other
guys of my good old childhood friends
one of them since my best friend since
the four years old one of them I met in
third grade and one of them end I think
sixth grade we've been on this group
text one of them's a hardcore
progressive one of them is a I thought
was always Democrat who became a
Republican during this election cycle in
a huge Trump supporter a doctor in Texas
who isn't happy with Obamacare and one
of them is completely apolitical
and became a trump supporter in the
course of this whole thing but one's a
progressive and then you of me is the
classic Aaliyah that's such a
spectacular text argument fight fun
memeing each other fiasco going on over
the past year about this whole thing and
at times it got actually pretty testy
and sometimes hostile not not me
specifically but but at the end of this
so I mean even today we were texting and
it's like we're all still friends we're
all still friends
don't lose friends over politics that's
the most dangerous that's where we start
entering danger and in the United States
when we start losing friends over
politics and family members and you
start being afraid to talk you know one
of the things I've noticed is that
people don't want to talk politics at
the dinner table anymore we had some
friends over for dinner and it was
lighting an eye in this way I'm guilty
of this one too it's two or three days
before the election and we had a great
time the men everyone was like so we
should talk about the election and all
of us at lunch for like five minutes
five minutes just that that there that's
it now this this election was
particularly insane so it was like I'd
seen these people in a while just didn't
wanna go down that rabbit hole but we
have to be willing to talk about these
things you have to be willing to sit
across the table from someone that you
disagree with and and break bread with
them if you can't if you can't then how
do you think that that piece ever comes
between nations how do you think that
how should Trump now ever try to
negotiate with Harry Reid if you in your
life can't sit across the table from
somebody that voted for Trump about as
regular so we got to be better than that
and I really do think you know Trump
speech last night was pretty good it was
pretty there was a lot of reconciliation
in there it was pretty decent and you
know the silver lining if you think
Trump is the next Hitler you think he's
this narcissist egomaniac or whatever
you think he is I
very hard to tell what he truly is at
the core as I've said I don't know in
his moral centuries but if you if that's
what you fear more than anything else
his speech last night was pretty solid
and don't forget this guy likes being
liked he likes being popular and he
likes winning so he is a lot of pressure
to now do good things for America maybe
he actually low rebuild our structure
maybe he will renegotiate some of these
trade deals and bring some jobs back
here so I think it's I I hope and by the
way Obama's speech this morning was
spectacular
talking about the transition of power
and that we have to have a smooth
transition and that we have to give this
guy a chance and all that stuff so let's
see you know do you like if you've been
Hillary right now all the Left would be
demanding that the right accept the
results and move forward and you know
except her mandate and all that so now
it happens to be the Trump one and now
the left is gonna have to do the same
thing on a curly selfish note I am kind
of happy that all my regressive friends
are really upset and whining and
bitching because they deserve it they
they goat this you your best argument is
that everyone's a bigot a racist guess
what
this is your mess it's on you love that
one or so the other repeating all these
winners celebrities realizing that they
they don't rule all people I hope so
enough of this [ __ ] the last week of
Hillary Bruce Springsteen out there Gaga
beyoncé a whole bunch of other ones
she's on the you know Katy Perry's in
her tour bus nobody cares what these
people think they're all part of the
rich elite that's fine I don't progress
them being rich or being elite you know
that's pretty good it you can make it
get make some money and become
successful in becoming influential
that's wonderful right
that's great everyone all of us would
love to have some of what they had but
nobody cares what they think to vote
nobody cares especially the middle of
Middle America and I hope that the
parties will realize that it's an enough
mocking these people these people are as
I personally happen to have lived my
whole life either in New York or LA so
so when they mock New York or LA people
I guess I am one of those people but I I
don't mock the people in the middle of
the country and nor would I I don't
think I'm better than any given person
you know you're a murderer I'm better
than you but like we shouldn't be
mocking all of these people just because
they don't live in the places where
media is abuzz because media is
crumbling and these people made it
happen
and by the way Andrew Clavin who I was
on a daily wire so it's been shapiro
last night said something that was
really beautiful on a slightly portrait
but he said you know for all the faults
of what's going on here in america and
for as dirty as it feels and all that
yet he said what a beautiful place that
we live in that the people just upended
the whole thing that does not happen
anywhere else really but the people just
said to the media to the establishment
to the elites to everything the media
just said are the people just said [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off we're gonna try it this way
and guess what at the end of the day the
system the machine is actually accepting
it that is the greatest that is the
greatest thing you can possibly say
about democracy it's a really beautiful
thing I think I just made what I ever
said even I said what do you think of an
oppressed part hammering the secretary
at the idea of having new codes and
being in war with Russia but Hillary has
the most anti Russia brother yeah this
is one of the things that I that didn't
make sense to me in these last few weeks
it was very obvious that the Democrats
were going much more hawkish on Russia
and they had reason to do it because if
WikiLeaks was in cahoots with Russia
which is what they were trying to tell
you even though they apparently had no
evidence of it but they kept trying to
link it and I think people started
seeing through that but that would have
implied that Hillary would have had a
lot more reason to go to war with Russia
than Trump so I think that look again
it's hard to know what Trump's ultimate
decision-making power is what he's just
you know what what actually is going on
in his mind so even if you're the
biggest trump supporter out there you
can't I don't think you could really
tell me that you really have a sense of
what's going on it's mine by the way I
don't really know it's fun in Hillary's
mind either I mean I kept you know my
joking with David in a mirror last night
like when she didn't come out and I sent
out Podesta it's like what was she doing
at that time
like they do they lost like what wish
was she drugged was she screaming was
she crying like why didn't they why did
they make us deal with that until this
but I would say just because we don't
know what Trump's gonna do doesn't mean
he's gonna do the worst thing I really
think there's an opportunity here I
think there's an opportunity here and as
a negotiator Trump should see that
opportunity and I hope he does and and
someone told me and again please correct
me if this is wrong but that he scrubbed
something off his website this morning
about not doing that yeah so something
about being pro-life so all the people
were worried about abortion which i'm
pro-choice myself but all for all the
people that were worried about that
apparently this morning within 12 hours
of being elected he had scrubbed off
he had scrubbed off my brother just
called me on the computer we could have
just maybe we couldn't connect but he
had scrubbed off this pro-life thing so
I don't think Trump is gonna govern from
a pro-life place I don't think he's
gonna govern from an anti LGBT place I
don't think he's gonna care whether
marijuana is legal I don't think he's
gonna be off getting us into these
neocon Wars so I think there's room
there's room for some goodness here even
if you think he's a bombastic nut bag
which he probably is what's Milo gonna
do I texted him last night he didn't
respond which is pretty pretty upsetting
he's got to be feeling good he's got to
be feeling good right I mean I don't
know what's he gonna do he's not an
American citizen so he can't be press
secretary which I know you love can you
imagine I don't know what he's gonna do
I mean the Breitbart people have to be
feeling good but now remember this the
Breitbart people are now gonna have
their guy in the place of power so that
does change this they they've created
this thing in the last year by being
against the power right whether you like
them or not it grew because of that now
your guys in power and are you gonna do
the exact same thing you've been
[ __ ] on the media for you're just
gonna suck up to power or are you gonna
keep them in line I hope it's the
keeping them in line and I promise you
that I'm gonna do that whether Hillary
and one or whether Trump anyone I would
have done my best and will do my best to
keep their feet to the fire is there any
hope of recovery principle is down on
the progressive left there are they too
far gone man I this is what I spend more
time thinking about that anything else
is there any liberalism
basically the progressive glass is there
anything left you know in a lot of ways
defending my liberal principles the
things that I believe that are liberal
about free speech and about the rights
of the individual and liberty and the
right to live your own life the way you
see fit and using logic and reason and
limited government those are classical
liberal values to any of those things
sound like progressive values to these
days progressives are all about the
collective they're all about the
oppression Olympics they decide how they
should treat you based on your race or
religion while they keep telling
everyone else that they're racists even
though they view you in this pecking
order the straight white man of course
is at the bottom of this thing and is at
the top of it the most unprogressive
thing there is that's why this is
actually regressive not progressive I
don't know that there's hope for the
progressives there will be hope for son
I mean I'm talking about the wider
movement that is linked really - a lot
of socialist stuff I don't know that
there's hope for them but I think
there's hope for a lot of good liberals
out there that's where you guys found me
that's why my inbox is completely out of
control with eleven thousand two hundred
and sixty-four emails right now that's
why my Twitter feeds out of control
because there is something brewing here
and again this goes to why a guy like
steven crowder who I disagree with on a
lot of stuff he is not my enemy because
we were fighting for a lot of the same
principles even if we see certain things
differently and we have that's what you
have to see if your guiding principle is
that everyone that you disagree with is
evil and he's a racist and a bigot and
that's all coming out of the
progressives well then then you're not
gonna have many allies to play with
you're gonna go you're in a pretty
lonely samba so and again that doesn't
excuse a lot of the alt-right stuff that
doesn't excuse true xenophobia doesn't
excuse true hatred of Muslims or true a
trait of Jews or black people or
whatever but I don't see a lot of
institutional power with you all right
and by the way I don't think Trump is
suddenly going to become a white
supremacist alright neo-nazi you can
quote me on what do you think of
comparing Donald to Ronald Reagan people
comparing Donald's Ronald Reagan I think
if this thing goes in the best
way that it can go that that would be
the it would be the ultimate political
it would be the ultimate story of modern
politics or even modern everything
modern modernism it would be everything
if he could really now say I pulled this
off I used every trick in the book to do
it I talked about little Marco and lion
Ted and crooked Hillary and I lied about
this and I said the president wasn't
from America and blah blah blah but then
when I got power I decided to do some
good I decided to build roads and fix
infrastructure and fix the economy fix
our trade deals and not take us to Wars
and not base my decisions on religion
that would be the greatest freakin thing
ever there is actually an opportunity
for that here I say this to you as a
liberal so if Donald Trump if you're
watching this and I hope you'll come on
my show on day I hope your people will
be brave enough to let you do it instead
of because guess what you're gonna
actually be questioned by the press now
and the press is gonna eat you and you
know what what's interesting here is if
one thing ironically Donald Trump in a
weird way has saved to the press I just
talked about how the mainstream media is
crumbling but now the media is gonna all
turn and hate Trump so they'll actually
be doing their job again if they if it
had been Hillary they would have loved
her because they clearly loved her so
far Clinton news network you look what's
going on the New York Times but now they
all have to hate him and that's good
because the press should be adversarial
to people in power that's how you keep
them honest but I I think there's a
there really is an opportunity for him
to do something actually incredible here
and we'll see we'll see if he does we
that's the part we don't know is what
will be what will guide will be the
guiding principles will it be but he
talked about in his speech yesterday or
will it be more of the stuff where he
goes to his his worst self he's won now
so he has an incredible opportunity
so somebody saying that he never had
written that he was pro-life on his
website so we saw an article this
morning
oh yeah okay so Julie all right it's a
little unclear we saw an article earlier
on PPOs comm that trumpet had taken down
this pro-life thing but I stand by my
reasoning either way I don't think he
will govern from a pro-life place I
think that the Christian conservatives
actually who backed him to the tilts
here may realize that he's he used them
as much as they used him they used him
to get power again and he may abuse them
just sort of like he used the alright
people to just get in power and now he
actually I think is much more of a
centrist I think he's much more of a of
a Democrat in a lot of respects and he
was a Democrat earlier and it's like and
I think he may have just used them just
as easily whitter just suspended clint
eastwood's account you know I should
mention alright so we'll find out about
that in a second Clint Eastwood's has
been suspended from Twitter can someone
get a make my day meme up on my Twitter
account for me please
Clint Eastwood by the way you know if
you want to see a place that Clint Clint
these do it a lot of people notice he
was the mayor of the town in northern
Cali called Carmel
it's called carmel-by-the-sea it is a
really lovely little vacation resort
with a lot of very wealthy people I
spent one night there on the way up to
Sonoma for my wedding last year and
they're doing some good stuff there so
he must have done okay I don't know what
did he do okay so this is a real issue
look they got rid of Milo we can we've
talked about that already but this idea
that it's clearly political what they're
doing it's clearly political you know
I'm a firm believer that twitter has
been shadow banning people so I see the
type attraction my tweets dead which
usually go on fire check out my Twitter
last two days it's been bananas but I
really do believe because I see suddenly
for weeks on end I won't see a tweet
from ayaan Hirsi Ali or Sam Harris or a
leer is B or even Lalo I don't see his
eat anymore illallah dekat she has no
friends with few other people I suddenly
just don't see their tweets anymore so I
really do think they shadow banned us to
kind of put us all in our own little
lanes to help quash some of our
influence so I don't look I don't have
any specific evidence about that I have
been told by someone that has a pretty
good connection to Twitter that that is
going down but this stuff is political
and that's a huge problem and maybe what
we'll see right now is that look all of
the left that was in it with Clinton
that these are the same people in
Silicon Valley that own Twitter and on
Facebook and on tumblr and YouTube and
all that they might fight back in some
really dirty ways right now which by the
way is why we do our independent thing
through patreon so I'm not only holding
to YouTube because they've screwed us on
our channel in some ways that's one of
the reasons I'm on there it's one of the
reasons I'm on I'm on minds.com by the
way I don't do much there yeah but it's
sort of like a break the glass in case
of emergency things for me it's mines
comm slash Dave Rubin it's an alternate
to Twitter and YouTube kind of thing and
I'm also on gab I think it's just gab a
I slash Rubin resigning because they
couldn't come crashing down on all of us
all of us that are gaining influence
right now all right very unclear what's
happening with Clint Eastwood but may
our thoughts be with good old yeah what
else do we get money but nothing in this
election that's an interesting one I
agree that citizens united is a moot
point because money bought nothing this
time you know that's the irony of Trump
so he look at all the things that threw
him happened that the left should love
money in politics came last the person
with much less money in the campaign
process he's got a lot of money
privately although we haven't seen taxes
he won right the NiO he's not a neocon
he doesn't talk about war
nation-building he wants to bring some
of our military back he's not beholding
to the Christian conservatives everyone
knows he's not a Christian conservative
he as I said I don't think he really
cares about the social things like
abortion regards these are all
[ __ ] my plumber is here the dogs are
freaked out for a little bit
she's been on edge you know so we bleed
so we believe and you know we're
building the home studio over there
electricians and plumbers all kinds of
all kinds of people coming but actually
he's gonna be counting them over here so
I think maybe yeah we both we won't even
go in a half an hour but you know I for
the rest of the week I'm gonna jump on
intermittently and do these just because
there's obviously a lot to talk about
with you guys and there's so much I'm
holding at once and it's cathartic for
me to talk about all this stuff anyway
so thanks for watching as always and
we'll do it again and you know I got a
deal
I'm not hummer myself I do I have
limited skills at the quarry all right
ciao